wir stehen vor einer großen
Herausforderung mittlerweile kann man
sein dass mindestens jeder fünfte
Deutsche tatsächlich psychisch
herausgefordert ist instabil ist und das
wirkt sich auf verschiedenste Art und
Weise aus das heißt wir können
feststellen dass gerade die Kleinsten
der Kleinen da wird gleich Carsten Star
wahrscheinlich auch was zu sagen können
darunter massiv bleiben noch nie in
unserer Geschichte in Deutschland waren
Jugend und Kinderpsychiatrie so
überlaufen in Zeiten des corona-wahns
gab es nur eine einzige Triage in
Deutschland die fand in dem Psychiatrien
statt man musste schon mit Selbstmord
drohen um tatsächlich eingeliefert oder
aufgenommen zu werden aber es kümmert
sich da keiner drum wir müssen uns
selber darum kümmern Gott sei Dank
gibt's aus psychologischer Sicht immer
wieder Chancen was wir für uns tun
können damit wir resilient und
widerstandsfähig bleiben egal wie groß
der Wahnsinn um uns rum ist
gehen wir da einmal direkt rein wo ist
der Unterschied für mich wenn ich sage
oh ich bin seit längerer Zeit schlecht
drauf wann passiert aber dieser Punkt
dass man sich eingestehen sollte ich bin
reif für eine Behandlung ich brauche
wirklich hilfe es gibt so einfachen Test
das ist ein einfacher Test wo man sich
selber fragen kann oder wenn man das bei
jemand beobachtet gerade wenn es um
Depression so depressive Episoden geht
wie sehr war das in den letzten 14 Tagen
am Stück das heißt hast du den letzten
14 Tagen Interessen die ich sonst
begeistert haben aus den Augen verloren
hast du den letzten 14 Tagen mit
niemanden mehr gelacht bist du seit 14
Tagen in diesem Zustand dann wird es
wirklich gefährlich dann muss man
dringend Hilfe einholen aber ich finde
es immer so Wahnsinn dass wir so lange
warten bis es so schlimm wird das heißt
in dem Moment wo ich merke ich stehe mit
einem anderen wir sind alle so extrem
gereizt und das liegt daran dass unsere
Gesellschaft wirklich viele
Herausforderung mit sich bringen aber
wir im Alltag und ziemlich dumm benehmen
und nichts dafür tun dass es uns besser
besser geht also mein wichtiger Tipp ist
anstelle sich auf Instagram Bilder
anzugucken besorgt immer wieder ein
Bildband oder ein Familienalbum und setz
dich mal mit allen hin und nimm dir Zeit
in Ruhe was zu machen diese
Entschleunigung einfach mal diese
emotionalen Trigger emotionale Reize
sind das runterzufahren und so weniger
emotionale Reize ich zulasse im Alltag
umso mehr Zeit ich mir für mich nehme
umso souveräner kann ich sein also ich
will ein Beispiel aufgreifen ich kann
Carsten das sehr gut verstehen dass er
da kocht in jeder Diskussion ist es aber
schwierig wenn ich nicht in der
Souveränität in der Ruhe bleibe einen
anderen tatsächlich für MICH zu gewinnen
das heißt wenn ich berechtigt in einer
Partnerschaft oder im Familienkreis
genervt bin und dann aber drüber schieße
für das immer zu einer
Eskalationsspirale besser ist es in
solchen Situation so Psycho Hacks so
nenne ich das ja Methoden zu kennen wie
ich mich runter fahre mich selbst
beruhige und dann souverän nach vorne
dazu gehen auch souveräne Forderungen zu
stellen aber eben nicht in dieser
wahnhaftigkeit und in dieser teilweise
wir erleben das im Straßenverkehr immer
mehr überall sind immer mehr Aggression
immer mehr Gewalt und aus meiner Sicht
gibt es ein großes Versäumnis in der
Politik weil sich keiner darum kümmert
zu sehen unser Gesellschaft geht es
nicht gut aber wo wird am ersten
gestrichen in der sozialen Arbeit in der
Betreuung von von von von Jugendlichen
dort ist kein Geld für da und wenn wir
uns um die nicht kümmern kommen noch
viel härtere Zeiten auf uns zu es ist
immer die Politik das kennen Sie
wahrscheinlich schon aber helle ist es
vielleicht auch dieses dass man zurück
findet zur Familie zu Kraftquellen wie
Herr Schmiedes auch gesagt hat wieder in
diese Geborgenheit reinzukommen Familien
gezeigt zu genießen verlernen wir das so
ein Stück weit na sagen wir es mal so es
bleibt für viele wenig Zeit dafür also
die wenn wir wir sind ja in einer
Gesellschaft wo zunehmend auch beide
Eltern berufstätig sein müssen um die
Familie zu ernähren das heißt einerseits
drängt man die Menschen in diese
doppelte Berufstätigkeit dann hat keiner
mehr für die Kinderzeit die Kinder sind
sozusagen ein Wachsen eigentlich eher in
peer groups groß was in dem Sinne
gefährliche Kiste ist in bestimmten
Altersklassen weil dort das rechte
Stärkeren gilt ja das heißt diese Kinder
sind im Prinzip ungeschützt wenn nicht
Erwachsene das quasi überblicken was
mich stört ist eben aber auch
grundsätzlich eine Politik die
eigentlich nie in die Ursachen geht also
es ist ja einerseits sagen wir mal
stellen wir fest okay wir haben jetzt
ganz viele Kinder vor allen Dingen im
Kinder und Jugendliche die gerade durch
die corona-krise noch mal massiv
gelitten haben wir haben aber schon das
wussten wir schon nach drei Monaten und
schon damals hat man es schlicht
ignoriert also was mich immer stört ist
so wir Kitten jetzt Probleme die wir gar
nicht hätten haben müssen anstatt dass
man einfach sagt wir reden immer alle
über Kinderrechte über was weiß ich
alles und faktisch tun wir gar nichts
dafür ja wir haben noch nicht einmal
abgesichert das sollte wieder
irgendetwas wie lockdowns kommen dass
dann die Schulen bitte aufbleiben ich
habe vier Kinder ja und ich habe im
Lockdown erlebt wie man meinen Kindern
sämtliche Freizeitmöglichkeiten genommen
hat wie man ihn die Schule genommen hat
wie man ihn verboten hat sich mit ihren
Freunden zu treffen die man sogar die
Sportvereine zugemacht hat und die
Spielplätze abgesperrt hat ja und dann
wundert man sich das Kinder psychisch
krank werden wenn man ihnen ihr ganzes
Leben wegnimmt ja und das sind einfach
so Dinge man hat das mit einer
Leichtigkeit getan hat man den jungen
Kindern hat man aufgebürdet sie sollen
im Namen der Gesundheit der älteren
Generation sollten die Kinder
zurückstecken anstatt dass es andersrum
ist anstatt das ist andersrum wir sind
für die Gesundheit unserer Kinder zust
und wir müssten alles dafür tun dass
Kinder Kinder sein dürfen
wie warst du das mit deinen Kindern also
erstmal meistens mit meinen Kindern
sondern es ist genau das es ist ja das
was ich tagtäglich war gestern erst in
Löbau und in der Schule mit 600 Schülern
ich hatte über 100.000 Schüler genau
deshalb vor dem ersten Lockdown habe ich
an sparen und auch ein Lauterbach und
noch andere gewarnt wenn wir die Kinder
aus der Schule nehmen aus dem Verein und
auch aus den Kitas dann werden wir noch
nie da gewesen sein haben noch nie da
gewesen Missbrauch noch nie der ganzen
Gewalt und die suizidschan werden extrem
die Hirsche wir haben eine Suizidrate
von 400 gehabt die hatten über 6 %
heißen da machen wir eine Sondersendung
zu dass aber was entscheiden
so viel Leid angetan über ihre Rücken
unserer Kinder und genau das was er
gesagt hat wir machen immer wieder
weiter und wir wir lernen nicht daraus
was habe ich im Moment
immer und immer wieder das ist etwas was
wir wirklich